Gordon's Late Late Show is getting a
special episode following this Sunday's
AFC Championship game and Chris is a big
part of that so leave it to James to
fill little that team with me you're
getting the most coveted person like in
Hollywood right now Chris Pratt big
engagement and you got them this weekend
yeah well I feel responsible I feel
swell I can't tell you what we did is a
big surprise but we all flew about four
hours away from here and we shot a piece
together and you really asked for my
advice I'm so happy I mean he is just
the single loveliest man you could ever
wish to meet when he holds you it's like
hugging a tree that will protect you
forever it's just adorable
it really is Sunday's post football
special isn't James only big score on
the small screen Super Bowl Sunday right
after the game you've got the most
coveted slot like people fight to try to
get that slot we have this new show
called the world's best it's a big
global talent show and the winners gonna
get a million dollars games host while
drew Barrymore Faith Hill and RuPaul
Charles are the judges and here's
something else we can't wait to see
James is once again sending his parents
to the Super Bowl they'll be there
causing whatever mischief they can
and I mean my dad's getting so grand now
no but he's not he's going through his
head it calls me the other day I said
daddy you good to go to Atlanta he goes
yeah listen mate I don't to be funny
but you know what with mums need we're
gonna be in business right you know
they're flying first class
you better believe well yes you're right
James did give in and he does have them
in business class first first James I
lady info okay step it up
you
[Music]